[Music]
i can't say i've ever just walked up to
an active wolf den like this before
we're not really sure what we're getting
into but we're going to give it our best
shot
[Music]
as we walk into the wolfden we've been
told that we have about 20 30 minutes
max to set up all the cameras the goal
is to get all six of them and then put
some sensors on the outside like these
guys right here when the pups walk in
front of them it will send a signal to
the cameras and if it's all working
properly all the cameras will start
recording at the same time together then
we can cut the sequence together with
all those different shots
we want to get the pups out of the den
pretty quickly we can tag them and put a
little microchip in them so that we can
follow them later on
and get them back into the den as
quickly as possible so generally we're
trying to minimize the amount of time
we're spending at these places because
the adults are somewhere in the area and
we want to reduce our general
disturbance on the pack
researchers have just gone ahead to the
den and they're going to try to catch
all the pups so we're just holding back
for a minute we basically have as long
as the researchers take to tag the pups
and weigh them to set up
all right we got three out a lot of
different settings that have to be set
right and if you miss one of them the
whole system doesn't
just put that work on
the cover on the side
you can tape this up while keeping the
tripod thread free
why is this no pairing
we don't have a sensor set up yet this
is
we're so close
i just need to turn two sensors on and
get a gopro running
the female was the biggest of all of
them tell me where it's on literally
just let it on
dude it's working
we got five cameras up also a gopro
inside of the den it's a really cool
shot come look at the gut pup's eye view
the researchers pulled five pups out of
the den so that was pretty cool to see
just coming out at the same time so this
camera was put up in a really great spot
we got wolf pups howling the wolf pups
out in front of the den playing with
each other
perfect stuff
the halloween is probably the cutest
thing
yeah definitely that howling is just
like makes your heart melt
that is just awesome
deep in the forest of the heartland
one of america's top predators is
stirring in just five months time
these guys will be old enough to join
the adults on the hunt
[Music]